[Music]
the demand on our energy resources is
constantly rising and having tremendous
impact on our environment this is one of
the most important issues facing us now
there need to decarbonize on a local
national and global platform are the
driving force to innovate the energy
sector we have been challenged to
transform the way we generate store
distribute and use energy while still
supporting global economic growth
Stanford's energy innovation and
emerging technologies program reflects
the complex and ever-changing landscape
as this issue has evolved so has our
program this multidisciplinary
curriculum is strong in inter manorial
creativity and scientific excellence our
goal is to demystify the landscape from
many angles help you accelerate your
impact in renewable energy you will
develop a bird's-eye view of the energy
systems and specific domain knowledge to
prepare you to be part of the solution
as well as understand the complex
landscape of policy finance behavioral
science and clean energy sustainability
all taught by Stanford's top faculty and
Silicon Valley researchers who have
pioneered discoveries in clean tech the
EIT program is on the forefront of
renewable energy technologies we have
witnessed emerging markets such as with
electric vehicles an inexpensive natural
gas and we expect to see much more in
our lifetime with modernizing the
electric grid enabling clean electricity
24/7 realizing zero net energy buildings
and more I invite you to roll up your
sleeves and join us to develop the
solutions and take part in innovating
solutions that integrate economics
business policy and technology
whether you're currently working in the
space or aspire to one day this program
can be tailored to fit your life you can
continue to work and take online classes
that fit your schedule and among the
many courses available you can choose
what you want to learn and complete the
four courses required to earn a
certificate this is an opportunity to
level up your career or transition to a
new direction
the skills you will learn here are
firmly rooted in what is taking place
now in energy innovation and pushes the
conversation forward to what could be
taken place in the near future enroll
now and contribute your passion and
talent to the solution
[Music]